شجب رئيس المفوضيه الافريقيه موسى فكي
وصول الاحداث في السودان الى الوضع الراهن
ودع الجيش والدعم السريع لوقف تدمير
البلاد وسفك الدماء في العشر الاواخر من
رمضان على حد قوله ومن ناحيتها دعت بعثه
الامم المتحده الخاصه في السودان الى
التهدئه الفوريه وندد مبعوث المنظمه
الدوليه في الخرطوم
بشده باندلاع القتال ودعا لسرعه وقفه ومنع
المزيد من تداعياته من جانبه دعم سولو
سياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف
بورن يوم السبت جميع القوى في السودان الى
وقف العنف فورا واضاف ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
مستعد لدعم اي جهود تسعى لدعم الحوار
والوساطه في السودان
ودعت وزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه البرهان
وحميدتي الى كبح جماح الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وتخفيف التصعيد لمنع المزيد من
اراقه الدماء كما اعربت روسيا عن قلقها من
تصاعد التوتر بين الجيش والدعم السريع
ودعت لاتخاذ اجراءات عاجله لوقف لاطلاق
النار والقبول الفوري للجهود الراميه لجمع
الطرفين في مائده مفاوضات
واعربت الصين عن امليها في ان تعزز جميع
الاطراف في السودان الحوار وان تدفع عمليه
الانتقال السياسي بشكل مشترك واذاعت
الخارجيه الصينيه طرفي الصراع لوقف لاطلاق
النار في اقرب وقت ممكن لتجنب المزيد من
تصعيد الموقف وقال مصدر رفيع في الاليه
الثلاثيه المكونه من الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي وهيئه الايجاد للجزيره
ان الاليه تجد الصعوبات في التواصل مع
طرفي الصراع في السودان وابدت اسفها
لاندلاع القتال وشار وكيل الامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه
الى ان اي تصعيد في السودان سيفاقم الوضع
الانساني غير المستقر اصلا في البلاد